Fibonacci retracement is one of the most
misused tools in trading. Half the
people using it don't know why the
levels matter. The other half draw them
randomly and hope for a reaction, right?
So, in this video, I'm going to break
down what Fibonacci retracement actually
is, how to properly use it on
TradingView, and what each level means,
and then how to apply it through the
Awesome Market Theory lens because
that's the most powerful way to use
fibs. Uh because on its own, a fib is
just a line, right? Layered in with AMT,
it becomes something entirely different,
very powerful. So, let's start with what
it actually is.
Fibonacci retracement is a measurement
tool, right? It measures
how deep a pullback goes inside a trend
using mathematical ratios derived from
the Fibonacci sequence, okay? Those
ratios show up through anything. Uh
actually, it shows up in nature in
flower petals, right? In in beach
shells, it shows in galaxy formations.
Um Fibonacci is everywhere, and they
show up in markets, too, because markets
are aggregate human behavior, and human
behavior has patterns, right? So, the
key ratios for trading are essentially
these right here.
The 786, the 66, the 618, the .5, the
382, and the 236. When price makes a
swing high, then pulls back, right? The
Fibonacci retracement tells you
statistical probability zones where that
pullback might end and where the trend
might resume. It doesn't tell you where
price will reverse. It tells you where
the price is most likely to react,
right? Big distinction. Fibs are
probability zones, not prediction lines.
So, here's the actual mechanic, right?
Let's go ahead and pull in
our fibs, right? Let's go ahead and do a
swing low, right? Take our friend. You
can hit Alt F. This will give you the
instant ability to pull your Fibonacci,
or I keep it in my favorites here at the
fib retracement tool. This is the one
we're using.
And we'll do a swing low
to swing high, okay?
Um in an uptrend, right? That's pulling
back, you anchor from the swing low to
the swing high is what we just did. And
then
you flip it vice versa, right? So, from
a swing
high to a swing low, we measure the
retracement of the bounce, right? So, in
the right context, you're measuring two
different trends
and you're measuring the uptrend with
the ratios, you're measuring the
downtrend with the ratios and the
retracement, right? Cuz it's Fibonacci
retracement, okay?
So,
one important distinction is the fib is
only as good as the swing points you
pick, right? If you anchor to a wick
that is a meaningful swing, the fib
measures nothing meaningful, right?
Anchor to a real structure high and lows
the one thing anchored to
uh that actually reverses, right? Not
just cosmetic wicks. So, you're going to
want to make sure you're always doing
like swing lows to swing highs
and vice versa. Um and then it depending
on, you know, the time frame you're
looking at, obviously, you can still do
that in the time frame in the intraday
levels in the scalping. You just have to
have the right narrative.
So, let's walk through what each level
actually signals and let's walk through
the swing low
to the swing high.
So,
first off, the 382%
and the 236, this is a shallow
retracement, right? If price only pulls
back to the 382 and and the um the 236,
that's a sign of trend strength, right?
Aggressive buyers didn't let it go
deeper, essentially.
And uh you have continuation likely,
right? 50% technically is not a fib
number, it's a psychological midpoint.
But it appears on the tool by default
because traders react to it.
And essentially, halfway pullbacks
matter psychologically even if they
don't matter mathematically. And you can
clearly see this, right? When we had our
uptrend,
touch the 0.5, the 0.5, almost the 0.5,
right?
So, 618, right?
618 and 66,
That's your golden ratio. We have a
video on this and it's a very very
extremely profound
tool to use, okay?
Um this is basically the level with the
highest statistical reaction rate
historically, right? So, everything is a
very pivotable moment and is most likely
to react in the 618 66 zone.
Um and then you have the 786, right?
That's the deepest healthiest
retracement that you can measure it. If
price breaks below this, right? The
trend is at a real risk. A close below
786 usually means the impulsive leg is
over and structure is changing. And I
can show you that in this example,
right? When we had a
major move pivot down swing low to the
swing high
and we take this across the board, we
can see that we had a very nice bounce
to the move up. We kind of trended
through bounce to the 0.5, right?
And then we made our way down into the
618 66, a bit of a reaction, ultimately
tapped the 786 and then we had a move
back up, retest of the 618, move back up
and then we had a good move back up,
right? If the 786 was lost
at this moment, right? If the 786 was
lost here
then it's likely to assume that these
lows would have been taken, but it was
held very nicely. And you have other
confluence to measure. Here's a daily
level that you could be measuring. Okay,
it came down and tapped the daily level
at the 786. There's a value area low.
Okay, that's a great place to look at,
right?
So, here is the mistake that most
traders make with Fibonacci and this is
very important, okay?
Most retail traders, um they draw them,
they see them, levels light up and then
they trade the reactions blindly just
off fibs. The problem is that at a fib
level just by itself is just a
mathematical measurement. That's all it
is, right? It doesn't tell you whether
anyone is actually defending that price.
It doesn't tell you whether real size
cares about that level, either.
So, the market doesn't respect fibs
because they're fibs. The market
respects fibs when they align with
something else that truly matters,
right? That's where AMT comes in.
So, auction market theory tells us
that markets are ongoing auctions moving
between balance and imbalance. That's
all it is. The tools of AMT, value
areas, points of control, prior session
profiles, that shows us where real
participants have built positions,
right? And for example, we're going to
take a fixed range volume profile.
All right.
And we're going to measure all of the
volume inside this
area. All right.
When your fib retracement lands within a
tick or a level of AMT, right? The
probability of a reaction goes up
dramatically, okay?
Because now you have two independent
frameworks reading and agreeing on the
same price, right? So, here's how I use
in practice, right?
Um we have this entire range built up,
all right? Let's measure exactly from
the
swing high here, right? Here's the swing
high, down to our swing low. And we'll
carry it over, okay?
Now, what you can see clearly is how
price has reacted within this within
AMT, okay?
You can clearly see that when we had a
618, we had an SFP touch at the value
area high, reaction down, and then a
push back lower, right? And the same
thing, value area high back to the POC,
push back down. We tapped the 786 just
yesterday.
We SFP'd value area high, back down,
bounced off the 66, right? So, there is
a lot of potential in AMT with Fibonacci
levels, right? There's a very very easy
way to be using something like this, and
we'll go back to again, let's let's go
and relive the fixed range volume
profile from here
to here, okay?
And let's understand exactly what price
was doing.
So, we have our swing lows.
Let's make this look pretty clean,
right? We have our swing lows
to our swing highs in this moment, okay?
And we carry this over.
Now, when price came out of value,
rejected value, came down into the 786,
we know that now price has essentially
retraced 78%
of this entire move up down into this.
We've reclaimed the golden pocket, okay?
We have some constructive price behavior
at these levels. Buyers are responding
at these levels. We also have a daily
level right here that we one reacted to.
So, you have a little bit of some other
factors like daily, weekly naked point
of controls, right? So, when you apply a
daily level,
reacts off the 786, SFPs the daily,
comes back up, trades into value, okay?
Then you have a more better narrative of
what is going on in these moments,
right? It's coming back into value,
right? Price is filling an imbalance,
it's coming back and then bouncing into
the market, full rotation back up into
something like this, right? And then
from there, you can obviously, you know,
pull different Fibonaccis, right? From
this swing high
to low, right? Oh, there's a 786,
there's a 618. Maybe we'll look for a
reaction at the 618 66. Oh, it didn't
happen. Now, highest probability is the
78 or the value area high, right? Now,
there's a lot of different ways. You can
also use the 786 or the 0.886,
okay? Now, the 0.886 is one of those
that is very um
uncommon, still uh statistically
mathematical. It is a very deep
retracement, but when you measure it in
context of the value area high, you also
have to understand what is at the value
area high. Is there a weekly level? Is
there uh a monthly level? Is there a
VWAP coming down into play into this
level, right? Do you have VWAPs coming
down into this level? Maybe you're
taking a a higher pivot pull from a VWAP
up here. Um there's a monthly,
you know, VWAP coming, okay? Now, you
have an 886 value area high VWAP. You
have a way better narrative and you
understand exactly where the Fibonacci
retracement falls into place here,
right? So, when we kind of talk through
this in every single lens that's applied
in every single balance and imbalance
and so on and so on. So, for now on BTC,
I'll give you an example of what we can
do with this. So, if we take our swing
low to swing high and say, "You know
what? I'm only interested on a 618 back
test as we like to do."
All right, 618 back test falls at the
value area low.
Now, let's apply what do we have at the
value area low? Well, there's a weekly
maybe kind of sitting around here and
then there's a naked point of control
sitting down here with some some other
NPOCs, right?
That's a very, very good narrative to
have because one, you have a value area
high
loss back test, right? We've lost the
value area high.
If we continue to trend down to the
point of control, that's the next major
value. Lose the point of control, flip
down, we look for the value area low.
And that is when you can say, "You know
what? We're at the golden pocket. We
should expect a reaction here. Maybe we
look for a little bit of a deeper
retracement. We tap a weekly naked point
of control weekly. We reclaim those
levels. We come back up into it." And
then I take the long trade and I have a
favorable risk setup and I look for the
rotational play back to the upside,
right? And that is how you use Fibonacci
within AMT paired with other, you know,
different levels like weekly naked point
of controls, which are essentially a,
you know, product of volume-based AMT
framework. So, this is exactly how you
should use um 618 back test, 66, any
sort of fib retracement, right?
You can even be looking at on lower time
frames. So, instead of the 4-hour, let's
zoom into the 1-hour and say, "All
right. Here is where price is at. Um
from this pivot to this pivot, where is
the 618? Well, it doesn't really seem
too favorable. There's too much of a
spread here." But, we could say, "You
know what? Price maybe will do something
like this. Come down, touch the POC, SFP
the daily, reclaim the 72, reclaim the
618, and then have a protective move
up." And then you can hypothesize and
theorize, "You know what? Maybe it's a
good trade to have for something like
this and trade this back up to a
rotational play." Um personally, though,
I don't I is a highest probability as I
don't like to trade near the POC. I like
the outside values, right? So, again,
when you have a move like this back up
into it into the AMT framework, right?
Swing high.
Let's take the swing high
to the swing low
and see where the 618 lands. Well, the
618 lands just here, but we have the 72.
I like to use the 72 as well. But, for
this example, we'll do the 786, which is
what we like to track. 786. We front ran
the weekly. We came back into value. The
short was taken. Now, we look to trade
this back down, right? There's so many
different ways you can trade this on
higher time frames, lower time frames.
Um you can even zoom out to the daily,
right? And when you zoom out to the
daily and you just kind of simply look
at where price goes, you have to have a
really good understanding of um
for example, right? If you take from
this pivot to this pivot right here,
right? When this was all playing out.
So, in terms of this hasn't happened
yet.
And let's say let's just for shits and
gigs, we'll do a
replay, right?
All right, we want to see what happens
when we take a Fibonacci pull from the
all-time highs to the major pivot that
it had. Where is price likely going to
react and how can it react?
Let's see how this one plays out.
Okay. Maybe we hypothesize that here's a
range high. Here's a 382. There's good
confluence here. There's a VWAP coming
into this level.
Um all right, let's look for a short
trade and we take that short trade,
right? There's a lot of things you can
use for something like that and
especially within the AMT framework. All
right, it rejected at the 382. There's a
wave three. There's a four and then we
have a better overall reaction here in
this entire context of things. So, this
is how you trade with a Fibonacci
retracement tool and how it can be very
effective. So, I hope you guys enjoyed
this video and as always, like,
subscribe. We'll see you in the Discord.